okay let's go next to our caller from
the seven seven zero area code caller
from seven seven zero what's your name
where are you calling from
yes I can okay
so this is more like a motive question
okay so some people actually believe if
this is a Donald Trump question more
like it
his followers some people actually
believe him what they said what he says
but do you think some people like simply
support him sitting for partisan reasons
you know like he's a Republican I'm a
Republican and doesn't matter how much
he lies I'm going to support my party no
matter how crazy it is of course I think
that there you can categorize Trump
supporters into three categories
effectively okay there are people who
are ignorant in other words they just
don't have all the information and
they've decided that on the basis of the
information they have which is
incomplete that they are going to
support Donald Trump that's number one
number two is people who and I don't say
this to ridicule anyone or to make fun
of anybody there are people who are
cognitively limited who simply don't
understand what it is that they're doing
it's not that they they don't have all
the information there's some kind of
cognitive limitation they just don't
understand stuff and how the world works
and then number three there's what I
call sort of bad people and I know that
that's it's an umbrella term and it's
not a totally fair term but it's people
who either for partisan reasons for what
people like Jonathan Hite called group
business are deciding that even though
they understand what it is Donald Trump
is and what it is he is doing that
they're going to vote vote for him
anyway and the partisanship you
described can be one of those reasons
okay all right thank you so much great
to hear from you